en fait le cinéma français a tellement
mis de côté une partie de la population
qui reste beaucoup de belles histoires à
raconter et mon ambition à moi en
faisant des films on écrivons un des
films c'est d'essayer de créer une sorte
de patrimoine pour le cinéma entre
guillemets pas de banlieue mais deux
histoires qui se passe ce qui se passe
en banlieue et des histoires dans
lesquelles on se reconnaît ni ne faut
pas attendre des autres qui nous met en
lumière c'est la loose
belfort
[Musique]
ce que j'ai essayé de faire avec le film
c'est de nous apporter une humanité qu
on nous a souvent volé la plupart des
jeunes de la banlieue sont des étudiants
qui veulent s'en sortir ou de
travailleurs il reste une minorité qui a
qui a cédé à l'est les sites mais ça
reste une minorité de toute façon la rue
c'est pas fait pour tout le monde
tout le monde n'est pas capable d'être
violent de se battre de na pas une
population en particulier qui aurait
cette violence dans le sang voilà ce
sont des choix que des gens font du à
une situation de précarité et aussi
parce que c'est un choix qui pense être
un choix facile mais qui en réalité
jamais un de bons choix
[Musique]
voir des fois on me traite avec une
certaine avec un certain respect parce
que je suis guéri dyens il m'arrive
parfois d'être dans des endroits où on
ne me reconnaît pas en tant que kery
james et on voit simplement comme un
noir parmi d autres
et là je vois que les choses sont encore
sont encore difficiles
donc c on a beau avoir de de l'argent
dans cette société en france on ne
devient pas un blanc pour autant il ya
toujours un moment où on peut être
ramené à notre réalité à notre âge notre
couleur à notre à notre origine des fois
c'est très c'est très violent mais en
même temps ça peut faire du bien parce
que ça peut nous permettre de ne pas
oublier ceux qui n'ont pas entre
guillemets réussi leur désir de nous
maintenir la tête sous l'eau transcende
ma motivation nourrir mon ambition
banlieusards et fier de l'être
on n'est pas condamné à l'échec
[Musique]